hundreds of schools are closed this
morning in Oklahoma and Kentucky where
thousands of teachers plan to rally at
their state capitols they're demanding
higher pay and increased school funding
the schedule strikes follow a growing
trend of teacher walkouts across the
country
Omar Villafranca is outside the State
Capitol in Oklahoma City where
legislators approved a raise but the
teachers say it's just too small Oh mark
good morning good morning up to 30,000
people or expect that today's walkout at
the Capitol and some teachers are
telling us they're ready to be here all
week to fight for themselves and for
their students the chairs are an awful
condition they're broken and they hurt
our teacher Larissa Kovac says her kids
aren't even getting the basics at
Puterbaugh middle school in McAlester
Oklahoma if you look through the stacks
you can just see how many of them have
broken areas and cracks Kovacs says
she's had to bring in folding chairs
from home to give her students a proper
place to sit she can't take the
frustration any longer as many of us as
possible we're gonna go to the Capitol
and we will rally several of us are
going to stay at the Capitol as long as
it takes
Oklahoma's teachers who are among the
nation's lowest paid have been
threatening for weeks to walk out on
April 2nd among the demands made by the
state's largest teachers coalition
increasing school funding by two hundred
million dollars over three years and
raising teacher wages by ten thousand
dollars on Wednesday state lawmakers
approved legislation that will raise
teacher pay by an average of about sixty
one hundred dollars but it wasn't enough
to avert a walkout Oklahoma isn't the
only state struggling with teacher pay
in West Virginia
it took nine days before a teacher
strike there forced the governor to
award a five percent pay hike and in
Kentucky
educators are fighting legislation that
they say would disrupt their pension
plans
Stephanie Winkler is president of the
largest teachers union in Kentucky
education in Kentucky is right now in
limbo and we want to make sure that our
students get everything that they need
a huge crowd is also expected in
Kentucky because most of the schools
there are on spring break in fact only
three school districts in the Bluegrass
State will be open today viana Omar
thank you